Hey hi I am very tired I just got home I
was in a recording booth basically all
day to day and I will be in a recording
booth all day tomorrow recording a cool
project that I'm excited to be a part of
which is also why there wasn't a video
today so as it turns out being sick for
a week really sucks
so basically I also this is how my vlogs
are gonna be from now on just like me
laying on a couch cuz it's very cozy and
I like it but so I was sick for a week
like bedridden sick I was laying on this
couch for a week straight and I wasn't
able to record anything which is bad
because I need to record anything
because back that da da
I'm leaving for Texas for a month and a
half on Friday whoo so so I needed that
time to prep videos and I don't have
videos because and basically I'm just
making a mental health like like
self-conscious like yeah I'm better to
take care of myself kind of idea because
I could right now I could go upstairs
and I could go into my recording room
and I could record a bunch of videos
that I could edit something for tomorrow
and I'd be up for 2:00 a.m. but then I
would have to get up at 6:00 and I would
have to go record and I would only be
going into this professional setting
with four hours of sleep and I wouldn't
be able to give my best performance and
I'm like I'm not gonna do that because I
really want to put forward that I'm a
professional and I can take care of
myself and I definitely have a normal
schedule and I'm able to handle multiple
things at once so I was just kind of
making a call because I have to prep
number one just physically prepare pack
get my ducks in a row for leaving this
Friday for Texas and then I have to
finish up some other projects that I'm
working on that are not
the one that I'm filming today and
tomorrow and then I just have to get my
sanity in order in order to be able to
everything go so I'm gonna have to put a
small pause on the videos for a little
bit I don't know how long it'll take for
me to set back up once I'm in Texas I'm
gonna bring recording equipment
obviously microphone camera and then why
not and computer which is very important
but it may take just a bit of time so
I'm thinking a week maybe it's like a
it's not an exile it's just a purgatory
you know what I mean
it's just markiplier is purgatory I'm
not an exile I'm in purgatory it's fine
I'm just meandering aimlessly through a
depravity filled land of nothingness
it's great it's awesome who wouldn't
want that so I'm gonna be in purgatory
for just a little bit I maybe a week it
won't be more than a week I can
guarantee that and even when I'm in
purgatory there may be like little vlogs
like this and stuff like that but just
for my own sanity to be able to catch
back up to be able to get everything
going and then concentrate on the on the
big project that I'm filming in Texas
for a month and a half I need a little
time so purgatory for just a little bit
it's not an exile shush shush your
pretty faces it's not an exile is it's
just purgatory and that's fine totally
fine so I am gonna go to sleep right now
I'm gonna go to sleep and I will see you
guys very very soon not that soon
actually probably not soon as well just
a little bit later let me let me purga
ties for a while and I'll I'll purga
late and everything will be good so
thanks for understanding it trust me
this is for the best because the videos
that I would make would be awful I'd be
so grumpy and it just wouldn't be fun
so there's cool stuff coming on the
horizon but it's just a battle of time
so thanks guys so much for understanding
love you bunches you guys are awesome
take care of yourselves take care of
each other
and as always I'll see you in the next
one bye guys